you have something you call a technology
Shabbat yeah me turn off food every week
yes I just you know it was too much all
this stuff all the tools all the
technology it was just hurting my brain
and and also my father was dying and I
really started to think a lot about time
and how to be more present with the
people I loved that were right in front
of me instead of looking at all the
people that aren't in front of me so my
husband and I with our daughters every
week on Friday night we're Jewish and we
celebrate Shabbat but not super
religious I'm way more into the rituals
of it we you know light the candles and
we turn off our cell phones on the
computers in any screen for a day and
fantastic it's changing my life it's
been about a year and a half and you
know that's great we just do different
things I write in my journal with on the
garden we buy we do all the things that
you don't do and you're like addicted to
your screens I find that so interesting
because I've forgotten what I done for
fun without some type of just I mean
it's amazing it's changed my life like I
feel like I have I get to reset my soul
every week and I it's just changed my
life but every week that kind of rush
towards Friday night knowing I'm get on
plug and then Saturday night this
amazing thing happens where I'm super
psyched to get back online I kind of
really appreciate the fact that I can
make text an email and tweet little you
know it's like you it has a dual effect
and then Saturday what's the one day you
want to feel really long as Saturday and
Saturday feels like this really long day
when you're not online because time
slows down one year
you